(tic tac)
♪ ♪ ♪
- Juin 1972 à Stockholm.
La capitale suédoise accueille
des milliers de délégués et plus
d'une centaine de dirigeants
du monde.
Certains arrivent en voiture.
D'autres ont la possibilité
de circuler à vélo.
Un moyen de transport à propos
pour la toute première
conférence sur l'environnement
humain.
C'est le début d'une conscience
écologique collective.
S'en suivra une éclosion de
ministères de l'Environnement
dans de nombreux pays,
et la naissance du programme
des Nations unies pour
l'environnement.
Le secrétaire général du sommet,
le Canadien Maurice Strong,
conclut que l'humanité vient
de collectivement dégriser.
La première ministre de l'Inde,
Indira Gandhi, rappellera que
ces choix difficiles concernent
tout un chacun.
Un rendez-vous est alors fixé
tous les 10 ans pour prendre
le pouls de la planète.
Tenue en 1982, en pleine guerre
froide, la conférence de Nairobi
tourne rapidement dans l'oubli.
Mais 10 ans plus tard, la
conférence de Rio de Janeiro,
rebaptisée Sommet de la Terre,
marque un moment charnière.
Et la société civile y attend
de pied ferme les dirigeants
du monde.
Même des enfants, comme Severn
Cullis-Suzuki, la fille de
l'écologiste David Suzuki,
veulent se faire entendre.
Les délégués accouchent
d'importantes conventions
sur l'environnement.
Et c'est à ce moment que prend
forme la Conférence des parties
sur les changements
climatiques - les COP.
Le concept du développement
durable, lui, devient
un nouveau crédo.
Le sommet de 2002 à Johannesburg
se tient un an après
les attentats du 11 septembre.
La sécurité semble être la seule
priorité.
Et l'absence de George W. Bush
mine les négociations.
Le président français, Jacques
Chirac, marquera toutefois
les esprits avec son discours.
JACQUES CHIRAC, président de
la France
- Notre maison brûle et nous
regardons ailleurs.
- Le sommet suivant, à Rio,
se déroule sur fond de crise
financière. Ses accomplissements
sont timides.
50 ans plus tard, les délégués
se retrouveront ici à Stockholm
où tout à commencé. On discutera
de ce que le secrétaire général
de l'ONU appelle la triple
crise planétaire, celle des
changements climatiques, de la
dégradation de la biodiversité
et de la pollution.
Mais en vérité, les attentes
sont modestes, parce que
maintenant, les grandes
décisions se prennent dans
d'autres grands rendez-vous
comme les COP.
Mais ce sommet reste l'occasion
pour la société civile
de se faire entendre.
Ici Elisa Serret,
Radio-Can